The last thing that we're going to look at in this course is animating the
suspension using Control Rig so that it reacts in real time to the movement of
the tires. Now this is really great to use where you want to add the extra
level of detail and you want your vehicle to have a realistic suspension
system. Now if this was something you were setting up on a custom vehicle of
your own it's important to think about how your suspension system is
going to work and use that to inform how your skeleton hierarchy should be
set up and how your different meshes should be skinned. And generally our
advice would be to align all of your bones X forward and Z up for ease of
setup when you're using Control Rig in engine but there are times where it can
also help to have your bone pointing straight down a mesh depending on the
movement that piece of the suspension system is going through. Some useful
things to think about when you're actually creating your skeleton for a
suspension system is for something like the lower part of the suspension spring
where it attaches to the control arm. It can be useful to create a bone at this
pivot point so that you can match that location in engine and always know that
it's pivoting from the correct place when the control arm is moving.
When you're setting up the rear axle if you align the bone with one of the
rear wheels it doesn't really matter which side you can then copy the
movement of that rear wheel as it moves up and down and aim the other
end of the rear axle towards the opposite wheel so always keep that rear
axle aligned with both wheels and we'll go over how to do this in the demo
shortly and for meshes like the rear suspension and damper meshes where they
attach to the rear axle you can actually make these bones children of
the rear axle so that they automatically follow its movement
without any extra setup in engine and some useful tips for when you're
skidding your meshes remember that anything that's a hard surface should be
weighted to just one bone so things like control arms and if your vehicle
maybe has doors things like that these should be weighted to just a single bone
and for the accurate visual compression of something like these
suspension springs the weighting should be a perfect gradient between the bones
at each end of the spring as you can see in this image here so the first
thing we need to do is create a new control rig asset and we'll do that by
finding our skeletal mesh so inside a meshes folder here with our skeletal
mesh will right-click come up to create and then choose control rig and I'm just
going to rename this CR underscore suspension demo and I'll double click to
open that up just dock inside our main window here and before we set up
any of the control rigs rig logic the first thing we need to do is add this
to our cars animation blueprint so that it gets taken into account at runtime so
coming back to our content browser and back to the vehicles folder we'll find
our ABP chaos vehicle and inside here just before the output pose so
that this gets executed after our wheel controller information I'm going to
right-click and search for control rig and then connect up the logic here
this means that we're running our our blueprint information for the car and
for the wheels first and then we'll be running the control rig information
that will apply on top of the cars pose and with this control rig node we
actually need to specify which control rig we want to use so inside the
details panel under the control rig class here currently set to none we'll
search for our CR underscore suspension demo and then we'll just compile and
save that and now we can start setting up our rig logic now the first
thing that we're going to do is start with the rear suspension because that's
the most simple setup so inside our blueprint what I've done is actually
move the camera a little closer up so that we can see the rear suspension
moving and see what sort of changes we're making to it as we update and
create this this control rig so the way we have the joints or the bone set
up for the rear suspension here is our rear axle if I search for it so
make sure I select the right bone and the joints location is the same as
the right hand rear wheel so what we can do with this is copy the movement of
that right hand rear wheel and paste it onto the rear axle so that wherever
that wheel goes this rear axle will also go so it'll move up and down as
this wheel moves up and down and what it also means is we can point the
other end of the rear axle towards the left hand rear wheel and what
that will do is maintain the left hand being following the left wheel on
the right hand side following the right wheel so let's get that set up so we're
going to get the information of the right rear wheel so we now have the
transform information of this and we're going to choose in fact let's
just drag in the rear axle as well we're going to choose set transforms for
the rear axle bone and if I plug up these executes just connect the
transforms and see what we get when we hit play you'll now see that we
automatically have movement from the rear axle that's being copied from the
rear wheel but we also have a little bit of rotation that you know isn't
exactly very mechanically accurate so back inside our control rig instead of
copying the whole transforms what we can do is just copy the translation
values and because we know this wheel only moves up and down we only want to
copy the translate Z axis so if we compile that and press play you can see
now that as I move forwards and backwards we don't get that rotation
that we used to get but we do get the up-and-down movement and because of
the way our bones are set up so because we have the children bones for
our rear suspension connected to the rear axle we get all this free movement and
compression of the rear suspension without having to do any sort of extra
setup inside the control rig but you can see on the left-hand side that it's very
very loose against the wheel and it's not really following mechanically
accurately so what we'll do next is just tell the rear axle to constantly
point towards the rear left-hand wheel and that should fix that for us
so I'm going to get an aim node here so right-click search for aim and
the bone that we want to aim would be the rear axle so if I select that and
use the small arrow here that'll put that information in there and we need to
set our axis that we want to point along and for us this is minus one in Y
and our target that we want to aim towards is going to be the left-hand
rear wheel so if I drag that in and choose get bone I pop open the
transform values we can pick the translation and plug that straight into
target and the executes and we can see that something has changed and
something has updated here and the last thing we need to change here is set
our secondary weight to zero because this is usually used for something like
a pole vector and it's something we don't have in this case so if I hit
play again we can now see that both the right side and the left side of our
rear axle is following each wheel and animating as the wheels
move up and down over these bumps so just as a recap what we're doing here
is setting the transforms of the rear axle based on the movement of the the
right rear wheel and we're actually only choosing the Z translation axis for
that and then we're aiming the rear axle bone towards the left hand rear
wheel and again using translations as the target so that the right hand side
of the rear axle always follows the right wheel and the left hand side
always points towards the left wheel now the front suspension is a little more
complex because it has a few more moving parts so we're going to break it
down into three different steps first we'll take a look at the sort of hub
of the wheel and make sure that that follows the movement of the tires as
they turn and as they translate up and down but we'll do this using a parent
constraint node just to show you a different way of how to copy
transforms from one thing to another then we'll set up the control arms just
making sure that they always point towards the wheels as they move up and
down and lastly we'll make sure that the lower end of the spring and damper
system is following that lower control arm so that when it moves we get the
accurate compression of the springs and just making sure that it's
pivoting from the right place as they followed the movement of the lower
controller so the first thing I'm going to do is just bring this back
here and actually create a sequence node just so that we can break up the
logic into two different flows oh well as many flows as we we want to so this
will be our rear suspension at the top so rear suspension there we go and we'll
create our front suspension just down here so the first thing we want to do
is make sure that the the hub of our wheel this sort of gray bit that we
have inside here follows the the tire as it moves up and down and we'll use a
parent constraint node for that so if I right-click and search for parent
constraint here we can choose a child bone or child sort of element of the
rig to follow a parent and what's great about the parent constraint node
is you can actually filter out different axes for translation rotation
and scale and that's something that we'll be doing with this so if we input the
information for our child and our parent we want the wheel front turn R
and L to follow the wheel front R and L so if we select the wheel front turn
R as our child inside the parent heading just down here we pop open item
this is where we pop the parent information and that will be the wheel
front R so if we connect this logic up and then play in level you can see that
I've just moved the camera a little bit so we can see the front suspension a
bit better you'll see that on the right hand side now that sort of
interior wheel hub is following the movement of that front right hand tire
which is great we don't quite want all the rotation that it's giving us so
we can filter out some of these individual axes but we have the
following which is which is excellent so far now something else that's great
about the parent constraint node is this maintain offset option that means
that it's going to maintain its position its initial location whilst
also having the transforms applied to it from the front wheel if we were to
turn that off what you would see that it actually snaps to the location of
that front wheel and we get some real funky results because it ends up
inside the wheel mesh so having an option to maintain the offset or maintain the
the initial position of that bone is a really great feature of the parent
constraint but something we know we don't want is some of this rotation
value so we know we only want the movement up and down and the rotation
the turning of the wheel left and right so for us that would be the Z
translation axis and the Z rotation axis so if we test that out now I just
spawn in a better location now we'll see that wheel hub moving up and down
on the right hand side there and as we turn left and right we can see that
it does only turn left and right but we're getting some funky results here
it's no longer rolling with the wheel which is good but there's one more
setting we need to just tweak to fix this sort of unusual movement we've got
and it's just to do with the rotation order so coming down here to
our advanced settings we have the option to edit the rotation order for
the filter so when we've edited these values here and for us if we set
it to Y X Z we know that this is going to fix our sort of strange
rotation issues there so as we roll forwards we can see that this of
interior hub is following along with the wheel and as we turn left and right
it's also rotating left and right which is the first step so I'm just
going to repeat this for the left hand side so if I use ctrl D to duplicate
our parent constraint with all the settings set up already I'm going to
change our front turn R to be front turn L and then change our wheel front
R to wheel front L compile and save that and when we hit play what we should
see is our left and right side follow the wheels as they turn left and
right and as they move up and down they're also moving up and down which
is great so that's the first step for us as our front suspension setting
up that sort of interior wheel hub and the next step will be taking a
look at the control arms so we'll first start with the upper control arm
and we're going to use another aim node like we did with the rear axle but
we'll need to add an offset this time and do our best to make sure that the
control arm maintains its original position so the idea is that we're
pointing our control arm towards the rear sorry not the rear but the the
front wheel hub that we've just used in the parent constraint and is
following the the front wheel so if I search for another aim node and add a
pin to our sequence node and connect these up our child bone would be our
control arm here and what we'll do obviously we're going to use the upper
control arm so we'll select that so our upper control arm and our target is
going to be the turn wheel that we have here so wheel front turn R if I
drag that in whoops drag that into the graph choose get bone and again
popping up and transform we can connect the translation to the target and now
aim axis we know wants to be positive Y and we can check this by seeing what
the orientation axis of the bone is so if you were to select the bone come
up to your options here and choose display axis on selection if I whoops I
disconnect the logic first you can see that we're pointing down the
positive Y axis here and that's what we want to point towards and our wheel
hub as it moves up and down so if I reconnect this logic back up set our aim
axis to 0 in X and 1 in Y and again set our secondary weight to 0 as we
did with the rear axle we can now see that our upper control arm is pointing
directly towards our turn bone so if we hit play in the level here we'll
see that as this wheel turns and moves up and down that control arm also moves up
and down and stays pointing towards it essentially but we need to add an
offset so that we can kind of reposition it to where it used to be
and and fix its initial orientation to do that we're simply going to add to
the translation values of the target and we'll use an add node for that so
if I just make some space here and drag off the translation search for add
what we're going to do in the beeping here is add 14 to our Z axis and just
through some trial and error we found that works quite well for our setup
but you might find that yours is different depending on you know how
your joints are set up so coming back into the level here we can see
that now it stays pointing towards that that wheel turn joint that we have
however it's now in its original location so that we don't have it
pointing directly at the bone we just have that offset to fix the initial
positioning and now we can repeat these steps with the lower control arm
so if we were to duplicate this aim node with control D and connect that
up we'll change our our upper control arm to be the our lower control arm
and the target is still going to be the transform of our front turn R
however the add value is going to be slightly different for this lower
control arm so I'll just duplicate this add node and connect the same translation
pin up from our wheel turn and connect that to the target and this
time we're going to use minus 4.5 in our z-axis and let's just
test that out so we can now see that the upper and the lower control arm
are always pointing towards that wheel turn bone and always moving up and down
as that wheels moving up and down as well and they're not affected when we
turn the wheels left and right so this is looking like a pretty good
setup so far now let's just repeat that for the left hand side so both the
control arms on both sides will be moving up and down with the wheels now
because all of the joints in our skeleton are Z up and X forward that
means that we can use this same logic on the left hand side so what we can do
here is just duplicate this with control D and just change some of the
values from underscore R or the right hand version to be the left hand
version so if I select wheel front turn L to be our target and then move
over to the L upper control arm and then the L lower control arm we can see
that we've instantly got something that oh if I connect it we've instantly got
something that is sort of affecting our our control arms here but there's
just one value we need to update and that's the axis so if we show the
display axis on selection again if I just disconnect there we can see that
for these two joints here the upper and lower control arm joints it's the
negative Y axis that we need to point because we're pointing to the left here
compared to the if I select the right joints compared to the positive Y axis
for the right hand side so if we just flip the Y value to be negative 1 for
both of these this is a great benefit of having all of your joints set up in
the same way like a lot of this logic here could be reused quite easily just
by changing one or two settings so if we test that out in the scene now we can
see that both of our control arms are moving up and down as the wheels are
moving up and down and they're essentially just following the movement
mechanically accurately so the next step that we need to take is to make
sure that our suspension Springs and damper system are sort of compressing
and expanding as the wheels are moving up and down so let's take a look at that
now with the way that we've set up the bones for the spring and damper system
they'll always follow the movement of the chassis so if we take a look here
the top end of the suspension or the spring system is parented to the root
which means wherever the chassis goes this entire spring will follow because
the lower end is a child of the upper end now so that we can make the lower
end always follow the control arm we've actually added like a mount bone or a
mount joint as a child of the lower control arm so wherever this bone goes
we're going to make sure that the lower end of the spring system
follows essentially dynamically connecting the base of the spring to
the lower control arm and this is a really simple setup with a get and set
transform node if we get the values of our damper mount here by dragging it in
and choose get bone we can then set the values of our damper end bone so
connecting up these transforms and connecting up the logic we add an
extra pin to our sequence here now if we hit play on the right hand side
what we should see is our spring compressing and expanding as we go
over these bumps so if we do the same with the right hand side sorry the
left hand side so find the lower control arm damper mount and get that
bone transform and then the front damper end will set the transform on
this bone again connect to the transform values compile and save and
now when we hit play what we should see that is our front suspension
system is fully operational so our springs are moving our control arms are
moving and when we move left and right that sort of interior wheel hub is also
following the movement of the wheels so that's all it takes for us to set up
the suspension system for the front and the rear of our vehicle so I've
just moved the camera back so that we can see both sets of suspension
working and on this rough terrain here you can see our front wheels are
working our back wheels are working and our chaos vehicle is essentially
complete now so if we wanted to we could go back in and tweak some of the
handling settings but in terms of the suspension the control rig that's all
set up and ready to go and however the wheels end up moving and we know that
that's going to react in real time to to their movement